So I wrote a book called the ants.
The world volcanic apocalypse is lethal
oceans and our quest to understand
earth's past mass extinctions,
but just kind of a mouthful.
But this talk and the book is about
the science behind the worst mass
extinctions and arts history.
So just give you a little context
for what we're talking about. Um,
the earth is 4.5 billion years old.
Um,
and we're really only concerned with
the last a half billion years or so.
So kind of just recent history.
Um,
and the reason why we're only concerned
about the last half billion years is
because this is really the age of what
we think of as complex life or animal
life. Um, before this, um,
some cool stuff does
happen at the beginning.
There's this thing called the late
heavy bombardment where the earth just
getting pelted by giant asteroids
around 2.5 billion years ago.
There's the great oxygenation event when
suddenly auction becomes an appreciable
part of the earth atmosphere and kind
of underwrites all the complex life
afterwards. Um, right before
the age of animal life,
there's this crazy period of life on earth
called snowball earth where the earth
goes in and out of these sort of global
glow [inaudible] glaciations that you
know, froze the planet almost solid
to the tropics. Um, on the other hand,
from 1.8 billion years ago
to 800 million years ago,
there's a period that's so uneventful
that it's called the boring billion,
and it's called that by geologists.
So that really says something. Um, so,
um,
much better visualization for this.
I just want an excuse to show this
picture because I love this picture. Um,
but the,
we're really talking about the top part
of the spiral here when there's things
like dinosaurs and a trial bites and
fish and things like that and all those
spirals back to the beginning as sort
of the boring billions I was just making
fun of. But, so we'll zoom in on
the last 500 million years. Um,
there've been five times last 500 million
years when more than 75% of life on
earth goes extinct in what
geologically is a brief period of time.
So this is on the order of thousands
to tens of thousands of years,
which sounds like a long time to us, but
geologically that is like an eye blink.
So we'll just dive right in. The first
one of these is 445 million years ago.
It's the end Ordovician mass extinction.
This is an still an
unbelievably long time ago.
This is hundreds of millions of years
before dinosaurs or pangea or anything
like that. Um, the,
the planet would have looked completely
alien and unrecognizable and here's some
evidence for that. Um, so you
can squint at this all day,
but I don't expect you'll be
able to really Orient Yourself.
But just to help out a little bit,
that one of these floating islands,
the one that sort of, uh, to
the west, that's North America,
it's mostly south of the equator,
rotated about 90 degrees and it's
covered by his mostly underwater too. Um,
and sort of the earth is covered
with a lot of these shallow seas. Um,
and that there's this supercontinent
that's slowly drifting over the south pole
called Gun Twana, which is made up
of Africa, South America, Australia,
Antarctica, India, Saudi
Arabia. Um, and interestingly,
this little island chain that
sort of down there, that's,
I don't know if you could see it,
but that's actually eastern New England
and the Canadian maritimes that in about
70 million years is going
to crash into North America.
So this is a totally different planet.
You'll see that the color
of the continents is kind
of this dull, grayish brown.
And that's because,
um,
the on land was basically
a barren wasteland. Uh,
there's no trees,
there's hardly any plants at all.
The ones that do exist are sort of
weeds around lake margins and stuff,
but for the most part, if you went and
visited the land in the Ordovician,
it sort of, would it look like what
you see from the Mars Curiosity rover?
It just would have been a desolate place.
Um,
but there is tons of animal life and
it's under the, it's under the waves.
Like I said,
there's a lot of these shell of cs c
levels are hundreds of feet taller than
they are today. So the continents
were flooded with these shallow seas.
And this is a terrible picture that I
took, but this is from Cincinnati. Um,
and if you drive around
Cincinnati, it's amazing. You,
you see just this gray stratified rock.
And if you go up and look at it,
it's just filled with
seashells and fossils.
And this is from almost a
half billion years ago. Um,
this is one of the most fossil
rich regions in the world.
And it's one of the best examples of
Ordovician sea life and the fossils you
find her from things that look like this.
So this is a painting of what life would
have looked like in North America, um,
in these shallow seas.
And so it's known as the sea without fish,
which is something of an overstatement.
There are fish,
there's sort of these
like jawless Weirdos.
There's one right there in the foreground,
but ecologically they're
not that important.
And the world is really dominated by
things without backbones, invertebrates.
So it's sort of like a world
of creepy crawlies almost. Um,
you have these things that look like
horseshoe crabs, kind of trial bites.
There's one of those.
And then the,
these big dominant
predators are a cephalopod,
not Deloitte or not allied cephalopods,
which are kind of the squid,
like things that are stuffed into these
giant ice cream cones and they would
have eaten trilobites and
all sorts of other stuff. Um,
so this is the Ordovician world.
It's a very alien world.
And at the end of the Ordovician, the
shallow seas where a lot of these things,
um,
lived basically disappeared because you
suddenly go into this huge ice age and
the sea level drops by hundreds of feet.
You destroy all this habitat
on top of the continents. Um,
but even things in the deep go extinct.
And that might be because the ice age
changed the circulation of the ocean and
change the oxygenation. And so you're
destroying a lot of habitat, uh,
thanksgiving, pretty bleak. Um, the
reason why you go into an ice age,
just thoughts that CO2 was sort
of dwindling over the Ordovician.
I'm to the point where when it reached
this threshold where then you go into
this huge ice age,
uh,
today we're worried about Sia to going
up too fast and getting really warm.
But I've thought opposite thing happens.
You know, it can get very cold. Um,
the reasons why CO2 is
declining or debated.
But one of the ideas is that
you can't really see it here,
but the Appalachians are starting to form.
Um,
they would have been this huge volcanic
mountain range in the tropics that
would've been eroding really fast.
And for some reasons we
don't have to get into.
That'd be a really good way of
sequestering. A lot of Sio two.
So this is kind of a weird extinction.
It doesn't really have much
to do with the other ones. Um,
so then we'll just jump forward this about
70 million years to the late Devonian
mass extinction when three
quarters of life goes extinct.
The Devonian is an interesting
time because it's actually,
there's a period of about 15 to 20 million
years where you have just pulses of
extinction where the ocean seems to keep
losing it's oxygen for some reason. Um,
but so as I said, it's a really, it's a,
it's also a really transitional
period for life on earth.
As I said before in the Ordovician,
there wasn't much plant life.
There were no trees in the Devonian.
Suddenly plant life is sort of taking off.
Trees suddenly evolve and they're sort of
invading the continence. Interestingly,
the first fossil trees or forest that
we know of on the planet were found in
upstate New York. Uh, when they acquiring
a dam to make a New York City reservoir,
it's this thing called
the Gilboa fossil forest.
But today you can't go there because
it's behind the protection of the State
Department of environmental protection.
So it's kind of a bummer. But, um,
the motivation was the seat without fish.
By the late Devonian renown this
period called the age of fishes.
There's this huge array of really bizarre
fishes. Um, this thing is a plaque dorm,
which there are other platforms
that look totally different,
but this one was sort of the top predator.
It had this sort of guillotine like mouth,
kind of a crazy scary animal.
These things have actually been invoked
for why our fish ancestors decided to
come onto land. Basically
they are terrified of things
that look like this. Um,
and then so also in the oceans you have
the largest coral reefs in the history
of life on earth, they would have been 10
times the extent of modern coral reefs.
And in the late Devonian extinction,
um,
99.99% of them disappear.
These things get hammered. Um,
it's a really bleak time and like I said,
an Oxi or the ocean losing its oxygen
is thought to be one of the big kill
mechanisms for this extinction.
And it's a similar thing
happens in our world today. Um,
so I don't know if you guys saw this,
but earlier this summer,
the largest dead zone ever and the
Gulf of Mexico was measured. Um,
this is sort of a seasonal
phenomenon in the summer when, um,
the Gulf of Mexico basically loses oxygen
over a huge area and it's horrible for
fishermen.
Uh,
you have these sort of tides wash and all
these dead fish and the Gulf coast. Um,
and the reason why this happens is
because in the middle of the country,
when we spread in industrial agriculture,
when we spread fertilizer on our crops,
rich in nitrogen and phosphorous,
it washes into the Mississippi and then
out into the Gulf of Mexico where it
fuels these huge plankton
blooms that when they die,
they take up all the oxygen in the water
and sort of kill everything else. Um,
so something like this is
going on in the Devonian, um,
only on a much larger scale.
And since there is no industrial
agriculture that we know of going on the
Devonian, um, one of the, uh,
reasons invoked for this is actually that
it might've been the trees themselves,
which is, it's kind of interesting that
one of the things trees do is they,
they break down rock,
um,
and they create soils and when you
have trees just suddenly invade in the
continents,
they would in breaking down a ton of
creating a ton of soils and sort of
liberating all these things
like phosphorus that we
sprayed on our crops a day
would have washed into rivers and then
out into the oceans and might've caused
these huge anoxic events.
Um,
and when notions went and Auc
sec and all these things died,
they fell to the bottom of the ocean and
over hundreds of millions years became
black shale. And this is actually
the stuff we fracked today.
This is from Lake Erie. There's
exposures to some of this black shale,
but a lot of the stuff that we've been
fracking in the last few years is sort of
dead sea life from the Devonian mass
extinctions, which is kind of interesting.
And actually the extinction itself
is in this picture. It's, well it's,
it's in there, but it's one
of those boundaries. Okay.
So more than a hundred
million years later,
we have the end Permian mass extinction.
This is the worst thing that has ever
happened in the history of life on earth.
This is kind of the all is lost
moment for planet earth. Um,
something like 90 to 96%
of species go extinct. Uh,
coral reefs have recovered at this point,
but at the end Permian,
they are totally destroyed and basically
replaced by bacterial slime of the sort
that you don't really see in the fossil
record since before there was animal
life. But suddenly it kind of shows up
all over the place in the Permian. Um,
in the fossil record,
you see things like, um,
there's sort of these weird things that
look like fungal spores right at the
extinction all over the planet.
And people have said that maybe this is
sort of a signature of things just like
rotting everywhere.
Um,
co trees disappear from the fossil record
for we can't find them for maybe 10
million years after this. It's
incredibly bleak. Um, and so,
but this is the setting that it took
place and we are now in Pangea, which, um,
I'm sure some of you have heard of.
It's his time when all the continents
were United in sort of this big sea, um,
shaped thing. And so North America is
attached to Africa and their stuff.
America and Asia is kind of up there.
You can see it's kind of deserty
and bleak and some parts.
And in the continental interior of
Pangea might've gotten really extreme.
There's evidence from Kansas that parts
of the interior of the continent was
like 160 degree degrees
Fahrenheit or something like that.
But there are places where life is happy
and at the end of the primary we have
this sort of happy ecosystem that
doesn't know that the end of the world is
coming. But, um, on land, the top
Predator are things that look like this.
This is a cool artist
representation of a therapsid, um,
which was sort of the, uh, uh,
Predator lineage of this larger
group of animals called synapses.
So these also some of these
look like bigs, rhinoceros
sort of things with tusks.
And um,
there were also these big warty reptiles.
And this picture actually makes
this guy look kind of cool,
but you look at other representations
of animals from this period and it does,
it's not really the most photogenic
time for planet earth. Um,
and then in the oceans, this is a
picture of the ocean from the Permian.
This is the Guadalupe mountain
range in West Texas. Um,
which if you hike it and you look
at the rocks you're stepping on,
you can see that it's basically
just made out of a giant reef.
The whole thing is basically fossils.
Um,
and it gives one of the best examples
of what life was like in the oceans,
in the Permian. And if you go to the
Permian Basin Petroleum Museum in Midland,
Texas, like I did, uh,
you can see this cool display of what
these reefs would have looked like. Um,
and cause see, life was very happy
in Texas, in the Permian. Uh,
eventually that died and was buried and
much later made some people very rich
and powerful. And in the Permian Basin
Petroleum Museum has a hall of fame there.
Then includes two of our presidents,
which is kind of cool. Um, anyways,
uh, so for a long time people want it
to, I mean obviously people were wanting,
we're curious why did earth almost
go extinct at the Permian? And,
um, knowing that a huge
asteroid is associated with
the later extinction of the
dinosaurs, which I'll get to, um,
geologists aware of that came to this
extinction other early extinctions looking
for evidence of asteroid impacts in the
fossil record. Things like, um, you know,
a crater big enough to account for all
the devastation or a layer of asteroid
dust and the false record and
they couldn't find it, um,
which came as kind of a surprise.
And,
but what they did find is that this huge
area of Russia that's outlined here, um,
is known as the Siberian traps.
And it's basically all entirely made out
of ancient lava. And when it was dated,
it dates precisely to the
Permian mass extinction.
Here's actually a picture from, from
you guys of what this area looks like.
And you can see the sort of dull brown
sort of stuff is basically just the
ancient lava. Um, and if you
go there, which I haven't,
but this is what it looks like.
It's just kind of these sweeping
plateaus of ancient lava.
Enough lava erupted at the end of the
Permian that it could have covered the
lower 48 United States a kilometer
deep, um, which is just mind blowing.
Um, people talk about Yellowstone
is sort of this apocalyptic thing,
but if yellow stone went
off, it would cover, um,
a few states and a few inches of ash.
Enough lava here erupted to cover the
whole United States a kilometer deep.
So this really is a truly
outrageous event. Um,
this might be something what it looked
like. These are fissure eruptions, um,
but since as extreme as it was,
it really only covered part of Russia.
So that can really explain why almost
everything on the planet goes extinct,
even if it's on the
other side of the world.
And so with geologist actually think
that it was the gasses that came out of
these volcanoes,
that where the the kill mechanism for
most life on earth and the most important
of those gases would have been, or it's
argued, would have been carbon dioxide.
Uh,
we know the volcano's would've been
capable of producing incredible amounts of
carbon dioxide and you can see signatures
of that and the rocks and it gets
incredibly hot.
Uh,
at the mass extinction when paleontologist
told me that oceans in the tropics
would have been the temperature
of hot soup, um, and when,
uh,
sea water reacts with the Carbon Dioxide,
it makes it more acidic and it makes it
harder for things that calcify there,
like build their
skeletons to stick around.
And so a carbon ocean acidification is
thought to be a major kill mechanism in
this mass extinction too. So those
reefs I showed you totally disappear.
Um, this guy totally
disappears. Um, interestingly,
he is on our side of the family tree.
If these things are called
mammal like reptiles,
so something in this and this branch
eventually becomes mammals. Um,
but these, these guys all
get wiped out. Uh, but our,
our ancestor must've made it through,
or else we wouldn't be here.
And it might have looked something
like this weaselly little guy called
Thrinaxodon, which somehow makes
it through this extinction.
So that's the end Permian. Um,
amazingly and the next, you know,
tens of millions of years, life recovers
and there's 25 million years later.
Dinosaurs evolve.
True mammals come around,
a crocodile ancestors come around
and coral reefs bounce back,
but then 50 million years later,
basically the exact same thing
happens at the end Triassic. Um,
80% of species go extinct.
And it's basically the same thing,
just sort of a mini version of
the end. Permian. There's a,
the earth sort of opens up and there's
another one of these crazy volcanic
events.
So this is the slide for the Permian,
but the world wouldn't have looked that
much different except for the fact that
North America would have started
to be pulling away from Africa.
And you would get this, uh,
system of riff valley lakes there.
And here's a picture of one. This
is in Connecticut actually, uh,
about 210 million years ago. And you
could see they're dinosaurs now. Um,
but dinosaurs actually are
not the dominant animal on
in the world this point.
Um, it's actually this branch of
crocodile relative, so you can see,
you can see one of them here and some
of them would have looked like things
would recognize as crocodiles,
but some of these animals are
really strange somewhere. Um,
plant eaters that ran around on two legs.
And so there's this whole kind of
weird world of crocodiles, relatives.
Here's one called the Carolina butcher
that they found a year or two ago outside
of Raleigh, North Carolina. Um,
so you can see how these things sort of
would have been the dominant animal on
the planet and the dinosaurs really
needed these things to get wiped out in a
mass extinction to take over.
And the next stage, so this is,
this is another picture of the ocean.
Uh, this is the Australian Alps,
which are almost,
or which are in large part made out of
coral reefs from the Triassic modern core
Reese evolve and sort of have this huge
blossoming but then are totally wiped
out in the mass extinction.
You can't really find corals for hundreds
of thousands to millions of years
after this extinction. Um, and so
for a lot, for a decade or two ago,
people thought they knew what
sort of, um, killed everything.
And it is, it was this crater that's in
Quebec, which is about 62 miles wide.
This is another picture
I took from Google maps.
If you just go sort of a little northwest
of Maine over the Saint Lawrence River,
you'll find this giant
circular system of lakes. Um,
and people knew it was around
the time of the extinction.
The problem is the
Triassic mass extinction.
It was 201 million years old or years ago.
And when they did this,
they found it was 214 million years old.
So this kind of came as a surprise because
it seems like this massive asteroid
hit that had been calculated should
kill at least a third of life on earth
struck during a period when it seems
like life was pretty happy and not at the
time of the mass extinction.
So at this kind of came as a
surprise to geologists who, um,
it sort of made them rethink just how
deadly asteroids have been in earth
history.
Uh,
this is a picture from on top of what
actually was the kill mechanism of the
entrust mass extinction.
So that's us in the background,
but this picture is from on top
of the New Jersey Palisades, um,
just over the George Washington Bridge
and the New Jersey Palisades are just
like the Siberian traps,
this huge expanse of ancient magma.
Um,
these would have been underground,
but they would have been feeding
eruptions and New Jersey to the west.
But you can find the same rock data
to the exact same time in Nova Scotia,
Brazil, Spain, Morocco, and
it all comes out right at the,
at the traffic mass extinctions.
So it's another one of these
insane volcanic events, um,
would have covered 3 million
square miles and lava. But again,
it's thought that these gasses that came
out of it really did the did in life
135 million years later. We have the most
famous mass extinction ever. Um, this,
the end Cretaceous is the one
that everyone's familiar with, uh,
66 million years ago.
Um,
all the non bird dinosaurs go extinct.
Um, we still have bird dinosaurs around.
Um, but all these iconic
species that people know about,
like t rex and triceratops, all are, are,
are there at doomsday and sort of
all the big dinosaurs go extinct,
but it's not just dinosaurs.
There's tons of other cool stuff
on the planet that goes extinct.
This is actually also the biggest mass
extinction in the history of mammals. Um,
they, they make it through, but it
also, nothing really escapes the,
the sort of sky of extinction
here, um, in the ocean.
Uh, these, this, this, uh,
artist rendition of an ammonite,
things like this had been swimming in the
ocean for 300 million years and all of
them disappear at this extinction.
Um,
we also have these sort of giant
terrifying marine reptiles.
It's like a,
this is a picture of a Mosasaur skeleton.
People think of these as
sort of aquatic dinosaurs,
but these were evolved
on a different lineage.
They evolved out of things that look
like monitor lizards or snakes. Um,
and similarly you have pterosaurs these
crazy giant flying reptiles that also
aren't dinosaurs,
but you can see here some of them got
to be the size of like small plants. Um,
and those all go extinct too.
So lots of cool stuff goes extinct.
This extinction I think has produced
the best Paleo are in my opinion. Um,
this is a painting of a t rex literally
staring down the asteroid, um,
which is pretty epic.
And I'm in this picture you see some
Pterosaurus flying by what must be the
Yucatan peninsula. Um, but this, this, uh,
this painting might actually,
this might have actually sort of been an
impossible seen cause I asked an impact
modeler, uh, what it would've looked
like if you had seen the impact.
And he said that the question didn't
really make sense because if you're close
enough to see the impact, you'd
be dead instantly. Basically,
he'd just be set on fire and you go blind.
There's so much energy
released in optical wavelength.
So it was a really pretty extreme event.
And they're,
the reason why we know there was an
asteroid impact is that in 1980, uh,
Walter Alvarez and his dad,
Louis Alvarez at UC Berkeley announced
in a paper that they had found
essentially a layer of
asteroid dust between more or
less the layers between the
age of dinosaurs in age of mammals.
And then a decade or so later,
a paleontologist identified this hundred
10 mile crater in the Yucatan peninsula.
That's, um, it's underground.
So it's that, which is why
it evaded them for so long.
But it was actually founder first in
the 70s by geophysicists working for a
Mexican oil company. Um, but it,
and it was found a thousand years earlier,
interestingly by Mayan civilization
sort of unwittingly because, um,
the impact structure has actually created
all these limestone sinkholes that
provide fresh water. And
when mind civilization sort
of sprouted up around this,
uh,
these freshwater sinkholes and unwittingly
sort of created this hundred 10 mile
ring that marks the asteroid
crater that killed the dinosaurs.
Uh,
I visited Mexico and that's called the
Chicxulub crater because the epicenter is
this coastal town called chicks Solu.
I'm on the Yucatan peninsula. Um,
and I went there and I would argue this
is the most important event in the last
a hundred billion years.
And this is the only memorial to it,
which is kind of sad.
Um,
the fly in the ointment of the asteroid,
uh,
explanation for this mass extinction is
that at the exact same time on the other
side of the world in western India,
you have another one of these completely,
uh,
crazy volcanic events of continental
flood basalt where this time enough lava
erupted to cover the lower 48 states
in 600 feet deep, a lava. So not quite.
The Siberian traps was still
a crazy amount of lava.
And then in the last few years, as people
have gone back to date this law, the,
the Deccan traps they're called,
um,
the most voluminous period of the eruption
seems to be closer and closer to the
exact time of that mass extinction.
So it's been really interesting to watch
the last few years as these sorta two
communities that have always worried
about whether the relative importance of
the asteroid impact versus the volcanoes
have sort of this more complex holistic
picture of, um, sort of a ecosystem going
on for all sorts of horrible reasons,
um, is emerging. And so just to recap, uh,
we know a giant asteroid hit at the end
of the Cretaceous for one of these mass
extinctions as far as we can tell,
we can't find evidence of a major impact
at the end Triassic the end Permian,
late Devonian or the endo
division. On the other hand, um,
there are major asteroid impacts of
time when Earth seems relatively happy.
Uh, and then we do know that there
were major volcanic events at the end,
Triassic and Permian. I didn't
mention it, but, uh, there is, uh,
another one of these big
volcanic provinces that's
been dated sometime around
the late Devonian mass extinction.
Um, it hasn't been data precisely,
but it's close enough to sort
of certainly raise eyebrows.
And then crazily enough, there's
also one at the end. Cretaceous.
So this seems like these,
this seems to be a theme of
mass extinctions and then
we have an ice age and,
and Ordovician and some weird stuff
going on with trees in the late Devonian.
To summarize,
these volcanoes would have brought their
destruction by extreme global warming.
Uh,
I don't expect anyone to understand this,
but if you go to geology conferences,
you'll see slides like this lot where
people have analyzed limestones and you
could tell it from the oxygen
isotopes that it gets incredibly warm.
And you can tell from the carbon I still
ups that there's a huge injection of
like carbon that's driving the warming.
Um, so this is for the Permian.
It's pretty unintelligible,
but so there's evidence of extreme global
warming driven by Sia too and ocean
acidification and ocean anoxia,
um,
which we see today or thoughts thought
to be major kill mechanisms and these
mass extinctions.
Um,
and this is concerning because modern
notions of become 30% more acidic since
the industrial revolution, uh, this
is already affecting a shellfish.
Growers in the Pacific northwest are
having trouble growing oysters around
Antarctica.
And also in the Pacific northwest,
you see certain types of plankton are
starting to dissolve because the water's
becoming more acidic. There's less
carbonate to build their skeletons.
And by the end of the century,
if we do anything like
business as usual emissions,
this stuff's gonna get really
grizzly with coal research,
expect it to basically disappear by
the end of the century. And Anoxia,
which is a major kill mechanism
as I explained in the Devonian,
is also spreading a modern notions from
nutrient pollution from agriculture,
but also warming makes it worse. Um, so
as I said, Arianna sixth mass extinction,
this is the question that
people are talking about now.
And I would say if we are in one,
then it started a long time ago. Uh,
there's sort of this eerie shadow that's
followed humans as they enter Luton,
new land masses over the last few
tens of thousands of years, um,
where all the large animal sorta
go extinct, uh, where they are.
So 50 to 60,000 years ago,
people showed up in Australia and shortly
thereafter you lose everything over a
hundred kilograms,
you lose these giant wombats that
would have been the size of cows and a
marsupial lions and monitor lizards that
would have been 15 to 20 feet long. Um,
and then 12,000 years ago around,
um,
we lose all red rom and humans
are showing up in North America.
We lose all of what we think of as I
sage fauna, things like woolly mammoths,
mastodons, camels ground,
sloths, all sorts of crazy stuff.
And then right up to the present day and
the past few centuries is people have
made these epic voyages across the
Pacific to tiny islands. They've, um,
uh, you know, you lose these big
flightless birds and land snails.
And I switched stuff too.
Now modern industrial society,
we're really kind of our foot on the gas.
Um,
it's a picture of an industry or
a shrimp fishing boat, but, um,
industrial fishing. Every year we bought
trawl basically just plow over an area,
the sea floor,
twice the size of the continental us.
And there's a picture of a shrimp,
what trim boats typically pull up,
which is 90% of the stuff they pull up
isn't shrimp. They, it's called bycatch,
which is just other fish and sea turtles
and stuff and they pull out the shrimp.
So there's huge wastes in our,
in our fishing techniques today.
And we also deforest a ton of stuff.
This is a satellite picture of the Amazon
merger sort of made in roads and are
breaking up habitat and things like that.
So,
so far our interacts with the environment
to the extent that it's been negative
has really been through
direct interaction.
It's been through hunting and
destroying habitat and things like that.
And I think if we just sort of relented
and let nature sort of go back, um,
it nature,
nature is incredibly resilient.
I think a lot of these ecosystems
would bounce back and, um,
we could avoid sort of the worst.
The problem is that in the
next few centuries or next
few decades to centuries,
um, we're really going to start messing
with the chemistry of the oceans and the
atmosphere in a way that has only really
happened a few times in the history of
the planet. And when it has, it's
been really pretty devastating.
So this is what a healthy
coral reef looks like. Um,
but based on just sort of business as
usual and even some aggressive, uh,
CO2 reduction scenarios,
ocean acidification is thought to destroy
most coral reefs the second half of
this century. Um, so
this is what a high CO2,
slightly warmer ocean looks like.
This is probably what coral reefs
looked like at the end of the Permian.
As one ecologists put it, we're on a
slippery slope to slime. Um, so that's,
that's all the bad news and that it
can seem pretty overwhelming and pretty
depressing.
The good news is that we still
have tons of biodiversity to save.
So earlier I said it,
it might be debatable whether
we're in a sixth mass extinction.
And the reason is that so far our best
estimates is that less than 1% of species
have gone extinct in the
last few hundred years. Um,
so when you compare that to an event
like the permanent, when it's 90, 96%,
clearly we have a long way to go until
we're in the same conversation as these
worst events of all time. Uh, the bad
news is that a lot of these animals,
their populations are declining
and the range sizes are declining.
And that's sort of the
first step to extinction.
And the best paper on this is by
a paleontologist at UC Berkeley,
Anthony Barnosky. Um, it's
called, has this earth six
mass extinction arrived yet?
And his calculation was that if we keep
up our influence on the environment for
a few more centuries to millennia,
we could actually be in the
same conversation as um,
to five worse mass
extinctions of all time.
So I think the good news is that the
world hasn't ended yet and we can still
save it. And we still have time to do
so, but we really have to act quickly.
And it's crazy that we could ever even
be in the same conversation as these
completely crazy events
when, um, you know,
and that giant asteroids hitting the same
time as India is getting buried in lab
and stuff. The fact they were
even the same conversation,
it's kind of amazing. Um,
there's reasons to get discouraged based
on sort of our political climate now.
But I would,
I would just say that it hasn't always
been the case that conservation and
environmentalism and kind of stewardship
the environment has been a partisan
issue. Um, completely. Uh,
I'd just like to remind people
that as recently as the George W.
Bush administration,
this is a picture of his,
him signing a Mac to protect
the northwest Hawaiian islands.
And at the time this was the largest
marine protected area in the world.
And hopefully we can start to,
I don't know,
think across party lines and agree that
we're all here and share the same planet
and that we should, we should,
uh, do our best to do so. Um,
so are we in the sixth mass extinction
yet? I would say we don't have to be,
and there's still time to save the world.
So let's go out and do that.
And just to finish, here's a cool
picture in New Mexico and at that,
thank you Google.
[inaudible]
oh, we're just going to kick off with a
few questions and I'll open it up to you
all. Um, so wow. Interesting stuff.
And I like how you have some hope there,
which is great. There's still time.
So tell me, what was your initial
inspiration for this book? I mean, what,
what started the appeal to
investigate all this? Well,
there were a couple of things.
One was sort of just like any kid,
I loved Jurassic Park and stuff like that.
And I've,
I've always been obsessed with dinosaurs
and I've made a point to keep in touch,
keep in touch with the extinction
literature in my whole life. So I've read,
Walter Alvarez wrote a book called t rocks
and the crater of doom. And then, uh,
this other paleontologist Peter Ward
wrote a book called under green sky. Um,
and that was kind of the first time
I'd heard that carbon dioxide might be
involved with some of these
other mass extinctions. But, um,
I was also writing a lot about the oceans
and when you write about the oceans,
as you can see there at the end, it can
get pretty depressing. Um, and then I,
I started to learn the story from a
geologists that some of the changes that
we're seeing today have actually
happened in our sister each. Um,
which to me was fascinating because you
kind of hear the story of climate change
and what we're doing to the planet as
something that's sort of simulated on
computer models. And I thought
this was so cool that, um,
the earth's kind of run this experiment
and sort of extreme ways, um,
and we can actually just go back and
consult earth history to find out, uh,
what happened.
Um,
and I also thought there was this sort
of unknown or not it had been told,
but I felt like the,
the message could use some amplification,
which is that in the public imagination,
people associate mass
extinctions with asteroids.
That's partly because right after
that crater was discovered movies,
horrible movies like Armageddon
and deep impact came out.
And so for most people they kind of
left it there and they think, okay,
mass extinctions are what
happened when asteroids hit.
And I had noticed that this cool
conversation was going on in the geology
community over the last few decades where
we weren't able to find asteroids at
the other mass extinctions. And it's
actually some of the same mechanisms, um,
in operation on the planet today or what,
what caused them.
And so I thought there sort of a news
hook and it's also just fun to write about
and volcanoes
and stuff like that.
Nice.
And thanks for speeding up time and
taking us through the five mass extinction
of those.
Do you have a favorite
that changes?
It kind of changes a lot,
especially when I was writing the book.
Every,
every new extinction I would
really focus on. I was like,
this is the most mind blowing
thing I've ever read. Um,
it might be the might be the Permian I
guess just cause it was so extreme. Um,
and it's,
I guess it's kind of,
it's not really out there in
the popular imagination, um,
the way it should be just cause it,
it's really what happens when you turn
all the dials up to their maximum level
and try as hard as you can to kill
everything on the planet. Um, so I dunno,
it's also,
it might be too extreme of a,
it's kind of good news
because even with the Permian,
which I don't know if we're capable of
reproducing, even if we do our worst,
um, one paleontologist told me I was the
best thing that's ever happened on earth
because 20 million years later you have
dinosaurs and mammals and stuff like
that and sort of this new
world blossoms afterwards.
So for me it was kind of amazing to sort
of learn how resilient the planet is.
Um, so yeah, I guess,
I guess the primary, and when people
say, so what killed the dinosaurs?
I've heard you say they're not dead.
Tell us about that.
Yeah.
So,
as I said in the talk that
the bird dinosaurs are still
around and that's not a,
that's not just something
cute that paleontologists
say like birds are literally
dinosaurs. If you look
at a skeleton of a, um,
like a t rex and a chicken
compared to a t rex stegosaurus,
you can see that the first two
are way closer, closer cousins.
Then the latter two.
Um,
and even like if you have a chicken wing,
you can see there's this little
claw that comes up, call the,
I think it's called a Lula or something,
but there's actually still dinosaur clause
and that's its thumb from a dinosaur
claw that eventually sort
of evolved to become a wing.
So when you look at a
chicken and a chicken's eyes,
you can tell it has this sort of like cold
Ref Tilian hello? So I don't, I don't,
I think it's kind of obvious that they're
dinosaurs. That's great. All right, well
we want to open it up to the audience.
I'm sure the rest of the, uh,
Googlers have some questions.
One thing that I was hoping you can touch
a little bit on is towards the end of
the book you talk about,
um,
when you start talking about
humans and like the current state,
you talk about how humans have culture
and that's kind of what's tied into like
why were so destructive.
The idea of like propagating
information in ways of like,
I guess going about like
destroying things in the earth.
And I was wondering if you can touch
yeah. And that, um, so a lot of people,
a lot of times people ask me like,
so when are humans going extinct? And, um,
a lot of paleontologists would tell you
that humans are incredibly existing,
extinction resistant. Um, and
that's because we have culture, um,
where other animal sort of have to wait
around for natural selection to kill
them off.
Um,
and their information is sort of pass
through to the next generation haphazardly
by whichever part of the population
is suited to the new environment.
Humans can adapt on the fly
by transmitting information
through language and
through books and things
like that. And, uh,
we can kind of get one
step ahead of evolution.
So that has enabled us to
rapidly take over the planet and,
uh, cure diseases and all these
things that would have like,
we don't get killed by
lions that much anymore. Uh,
all these things that would sort of take
out other animals we can adapt to on
the fly because we have this
incredibly, uh, adaptive,
malleable information transmission
system that is much more powerful.
You could argue the natural selection.
So I don't know if that's right.
Um, hi. Um,
in recent years we learned about the,
that we broke the limit of Sio two in the
atmosphere, the 400 parts per million.
Yeah.
And it's considered kind of like a brake
line and that it may lead to what is
called a cascade effect by the defrosting
of Siberia and more methane being
released and so on and so forth.
Is that actually your deadline is,
or are we going to see something
like that in the next coming years?
So I know there,
there has been this fear for a long time
that we could destabilize these huge
reservoir is a methane and kickoff this
like completely catastrophic warming. Um,
within a few decades. I think the
more people have looked into that,
it doesn't seem like these huge reserves
are capable of sort of a catastrophic
destabilization, but certainly
over thousands of years, um,
the earth is going to get a lot
more warmer than it is today. Uh,
we know that the main driver of climate
for the last 60 million years or so is
the atmospheric concentration
of carbon dioxide.
And the last time it was 400
parts per million was the,
I think it was apply a scene.
Um, but we're expected when
sea level was, I dunno,
it's like 30 meters or something
higher than us today. Uh,
so over thousands of years,
ice is going to keep melting and sea
level's going to go up and we're going to
transition to this much warmer world.
Um,
whether or not it will take place on
a short enough time scale that'll be
catastrophic to civilization, I
think is still an open question. Um,
but we're headed towards,
people talk about,
it could be five degrees
warmer, um, by the end of the
century and you think, okay,
five degrees,
if that's not that big of a deal
last time it's five degrees warmer.
There was no ice on Antarctica.
Um,
or at least in times of the past
when it's been five degrees warmer,
there's no ice in Antarctica and we're
talking about going over a hundred parts
per million co two.
And that brings you back to like
the eoscene when there were um,
palm trees in Alaska and stuff like that.
And so maybe in a few centuries to
millennia we might actually recreate that
world,
but I think the next few centuries,
or I mean the next few
decades there's going to be,
it'll get warmer and sea level go up.
But I don't know if it would be quite
on a catastrophic. I mean it will be,
it could be,
it will be catastrophic,
but Antarctica is not going
to melt completely tomorrow.
Thank you.
It was wondering,
so if 86 or 90% of animals go extinct,
so it's not 100%.
So what are the retreats for those
little creatures then kind of survive?
Did they settle on mountain top?
So where did they go?
Yeah, so there's these theorize
things called Refugia, um,
where animals sort of waited out until
conditions get better and then they can
flourish scan.
But that's sort of just a,
a name that we've given to a
phenomenon we don't understand quite,
it's sort of like dark matter.
It's like a placeholder because for the
most part we don't really know where the
Refugio are,
but it's easy to make life really
miserable in certain parts of the planet,
but it's very hard to wipe out everything
and every deep sea canyon and Mountain
Valley everywhere on the planet of
every size. And it's really hard to,
to wipe out all of life on earth.
It seems based on these mass extinctions.
I think it's in one of
the freakonomics books,
they talk about the scientists who,
um,
found that volcano eruptions bring down
the amount of co two in the atmosphere
and like serve to kind of cool the planet.
There was this group of people who are
trying to make like these artificial
volcanic eruptions in Antarctica.
And so how do you reconcile that with
what you're saying before when you have
these huge volcanic eruptions that brings
so much co two into the atmosphere and
leaning to extreme heating?
Right.
So that's a good question
because there's probably,
people use the word super volcano at tuns
tends to mean a few different things.
Um, but yeah, explosive, uh,
sort of strata volcanoes that we see
around the planet today inject a lot of
software aerosols that dim them,
reduce the amount of sunlight that can
come into the atmosphere and it makes it
cooler temporarily.
And that might have been a component.
There might've been short term cooling
and some of these mass extinctions. Um,
we don't see any evidence of that in
the fossil record and it seems to be
swamped by it this thousands and
thousands of years of extreme warming,
but there might have been sort of
cold snaps and things like that.
What you're talking about with the Geo
engineering by shooting sulfur sulfate,
aerosols and to this guy.
Um,
so there's some scary studies on that
that if for any reason we'd have to,
if we started doing that, we'd have to
keep doing it basically forever. Um,
because if you stop after
a couple of years, the,
the sulfur rains out and
people who have modeled this,
then in the meantime,
if you keep building up carbon emissions
while you're managing it by reducing
the amount of sunlight, if that's stuff
rains out, suddenly warming spikes like,
and just a few years,
you can jump up for like four
degrees or something like that.
And that would be totally catastrophic.
So when we're planning on how
we're going to address warming,
I'm not a huge fan of, uh, that kind
of geoengineering because it relies on,
um,
sort of global international agreements
that are perfectly enforced forever.
And based on, you know, I don't know,
recent global geopolitics that
prospect kind of frightens me,
but that could have been a
killing mechanism in the,
in these extinctions too,
is that you have the sulfate aerosols
that are blocking sunlight at the same
time. You're building carbon.
And then when it gets rained out,
suddenly have these huge warming spikes.
So maybe we shouldn't try and
recreate these like mass extinction,
I guess.
Yeah.
Hi. Um, so you talked about
how these media or events, um,
occasionally do, but also do not
correlate with mass extinctions,
but there's a, there's a greater
correlation with these, uh, you know,
apocalyptic lava flows.
Uh,
are there examples of times where there've
been huge lava events that haven't
affected life on earth or at least not
to the same extent. And in general, what,
um, what causes these, you know, huge
lava events and, and how do they work?
Uh, that's a great question. And um, yeah,
I didn't want to overcomplicate things,
but there is one,
there's one,
I think it's a 130 million years
ago or so called the prawn,
the eights and Decca traps in South
America that are maybe as big as the ones
associated with the mass extinctions.
And it similar lately,
it doesn't seem like
anything goes extinct.
People have argued that
maybe that's because it was
over a longer time period or
maybe it was based on the rocks that
they were going coming through. Um,
so that the Siberian traps we also know
would have burned through the one of the
world's largest coal basins
and what burned through all
these carbon rich rocks.
And that would have been another way
of getting a ton of co two in the air.
And maybe if you're,
if you're coming up through rocket isn't
quite as filled with as many volatiles,
then a, you can't quite get
to a mass extinction. Um,
but that's definitely a definitely an
active area of inquiry as to what causes
them
that starts to get into some really
deep like geophysical questions.
Uh, but there's sort of these theories,
these things called mantle plumes,
which are just, you know,
the mantles convicting.
And then every once in a while
you get this like big blue,
like plastic blog that just emerges,
um,
just rocketing to the surface.
Um,
I know in the Triassic they think that
one of the sort of factors that might've
made it easier for one of these things
to happen is that as the continents are
pulling apart,
that the crust would have been weaker.
And it might've been a weak spot for one
of these things to break through to the
surface and be as catastrophic as
it is. But yeah, why they happen,
I don't really get into the book and I
kind of just paper over that. But yeah,
mantle plumes,
I guess.
Yeah.
Although those stellar theoretical,
that's just,
people have modeled things like that,
but no one has ever,
I don't think really founded direct
evidence of mental loans right now though.
I might get in trouble for saying this
stuff because everything in the book,
I'm interviewing geologists and things,
I'm a science journalist,
so for me to have an opinion about this
stuff is I'm a little out of my depth
and doing so, but, um, I'm reporting what,
what I take from these geological
meetings and these interviews and reading
these books.
So,
okay.
Thank you.